yes we're all locked in and doing all
right Angelina Jolie is talking locked
down with six kids I'm so happy to have
with us Angelina Jolie the actors
appeared in the first ever time 100
talks with the magazine's
editor-in-chief Angelina thank you so
much for being with us very very happy
to be here with everyone and she
revealed during the video chat that
she's at home with all six of her
children
eighteen-year-old Maddox 16 year old pax
15 year old Zahara 13 year old Shiloh
and 11 year old twins Knox and Vivian
moms everywhere saying how the heck does
she do that and make it look so easy
wrangling them all and having they
wrangle me honestly they're more
together Sahar is the most organized in
the family eldest son Maddox is back in
America after a semester of college in
South Korea taking Maddox and send him
off to college is everybody kind of like
walking around in a daze missing him it
was of what was very beautiful so
everybody say goodbye and when it was
time for him to you know take him to the
airport and some jumped in the car to
take him and everybody was a bit every
but everybody just when you know that
your kids love each other and you see
the way they all without any kind of
prompting or pushing give each other
notes hug each other take care of each
other support each other then you feel
like they're gonna be okay and they're
gonna always have each other
Angelina who is a contributing editor
for time spoke about how children are
affected by the pandemic the two most
different the two things that affect
children from from my view the most
being out of school of course the
education and the challenges of
Education I know parents across it even
the you know this country are challenged
with home school and this that's maybe
more of a challenge on the parents than
the the children yeah she just made a
home schooling joke you've gotta wonder
what that looks like at the Jolie
residence it's just so wonderful to have
there
neither my friends but then the Oscar
winner got serious advocating for
vulnerable children who are in
situations amplified by the pandemic
it's the food food insecurity that
affects 11 million children severe
insecurity 11 19 children 20 million on
on these food stamps and dependent and
it's in its domestic violence and abuse
when a child goes to school it is a it
is a place where you can temporarily get
away from the violence or the horrors if
you live in one of those homes
Angelina offered this message of hope I
believe I believe in I have hope and I I
think we really can't afford not to have
hope so I think what people are aware
and if they can have a path forward
guiding them with how to help and what
to do they will
[Music]